ok
[Musique]
ap
charaf
[Musique]
comment
ça vous pouvez l'applaudir
[Musique]
le soir
voilà le flash lequel il a allumé son
téléphone toute la soirée ça doumbia te
vois au prix ce ton sourire des
surprises en plus il ça on a on a on a
au delà de ça on a à merci vous êtes
donc bon soir tout le monde ça tout le
monde c'était qu'ils font vraiment
franchement je trouve ça bien merci
et à chaque fois en fait après toi tu
vas pleurer quand je dire des trucs mais
bon à chaque fois que tu ne l'as pas
basse basse bosse on a eu la course le
féminisme tout à l'heure mais si on a
tous connu tu viens de finir de
travailler chez darty jeta passer des
fringues assez bon merci papa fou un
pardon excusez moi je vous ai coupé non
ça va non je voulais dire juste un truc
en fait je me suis aperçu que j'avais
déjà joué dans cette salle c'est bernard
est un spectacle avec papy et ouais
c'est vrai et la joie ici tu étais mon
beau père
exactement enfin on va pas raconter mais
mais mais mais justement c'est vrai que
c'est un souvenir
on en a plein et qui ça parce que
forcément il vient de vienne de la
maison deviennent des kits théâtre et on
se connaît depuis longtemps et il y
avait un spectacle qui s'appelait face à
face et qu'on a joué ici est
effectivement dans ce personnage enfin
j'étais marié à sa fille et je me
rappelle très bien en bas dans la salle
de répète m'ont donné on avait un indu
où je me retrouve avec mon beau-père et
on s'est dit
viens on sait faire ça on va improviser
quelque chose et j'avoue que ça a été un
moment d'anthologie tous les deuxièmes
franchement c'était bon c'était pas mal
mais je pense que les gens s'en foutent
un peu de ça à bombay non justement en
fait on voulait est invité pour parler
tous ensemble déjà roi voilà tu as ta
place est plus que n'importe qui ici au
nom si tout cela se soit franchement
mieux ce que vous achetez sur ce match
ça fait vraiment sens et on s'est dit
que ce soir ce serait peut-être le
moment aussi si vous avez des questions
à pourrissent abbas et moment il est là
il est sous vos yeux ébahis et si ça ne
te dérange pas pas du tout coincé et
surtout bah si tu pouvais nous raconter
un peu ce qui t'arrive moi c'est
pourquoi par exemple bien mathieu qui a
joué il est tout à l'heure et ça m'a
beaucoup touché limite ému parce que
c'était mon élève d'un pro donc du coup
quand je le vois sur scène et qui qui
s'est toujours bien se tenir et qui sait
bien gigoter sur scène mais bon il ya
encore du travail on va en parler tout à
l'heure
mais secousse a déjà tellement courageux
vous savez pas comment c'est
traumatisant de monter sur scène parce
que monter sur scène tout seul face à un
public qui attend de rire c'est toujours
compliqué donc du coup juste de venir et
de comment non ça c'est quand même un
public courtois et courtoise cette
blague faut que tu arrêtes papé oui mais
moi je sais qu'une blague
oui je te connais tu vas y aller
jusqu'au bout voilà mais avant ils sont
en voiture l'appareil n'ont été pas mal
quand même courtois courtois n'a sa élan
courtois
ouais c'est quand même bien merci c'est
gentil je continue à me la faire tout
seul la base très bien continuer à
essayer de la faire sur la place du
marché
basic ici copains faut pas parler du
marché très bien alors ils ont que donc
je disais que c'était très courageux de
monter sur scène et est ce qu'il est ce
qu'il ya déjà des gens en salles qui
sont déjà montés sur scène ici ou pas du
tout ou qu'on a envie de monter sur
scène
oui la charmante jeune fille tabac qui
quittent fille petit peu lever la main
tu as le droit tu seras pas juger
pensent que c'est facile de monter sur
scène c'est bien sécurisé
ben vas-y vient ici ah oui bah
maintenant faut venir investir lâcher ce
bien commun chaussettes maintenant mais
il faut que tu aies pas op der laan
pauvres allez pour leur gardien bien
qu'elle avait un gros faux pas bien et
c'est thomas bravo les parents et tu
vois déjà c'est pas facile de monter sur
le tas boel a été tu viens tu as un pull
un manteau tiens toi je te casse mon
micro comment tu t'appelles tu es un
gars théodore tu as quel âge
si vingt six ans non mais attendez
attention gros pull bear tout à l'heure
j'ai dit mon prénom personne n'a
applaudi ok donc ce que j'aime c'est que
les enfants ils ont pas de fille friggit
livra il s'en fout et à vue il ya plein
d'adultes si c'est ton micro une marche
inquiète pas je veux parler de dents
vas-y par allot vois tu t'entends est-ce
que générer chez les ch qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez allumer la lumière est ce
que vous pouvez allumer la salle s'il
vous plaît si c'est possible ou pas non
voilà tu as vu tous les gens qui a dans
la salle n'est là que beaucoup
commencent maintenant il en train de les
compter cette issue heureuse non je ne
fais pas cet exercice t'as vu ça fait
beaucoup quand même
et tu vois c'est pareil côté quand tu es
au tableau à l'école tu vois si c'est
compliqué de parler devant tout le monde
on est bien d'accord ouais eh ben c'est
pour ça que vous vous êtes les un public
important parce que vous êtes là pour
soutenir les gens et tout ça et du coup
c'est pas facile donc franchement les
applaudir c'est vraiment cool tu sais
toi qu'ils ont des pieds comme ça non
cher maintenant
excuse moi
au niveau de l'hygiène de l'enfant
comment ça se passe faut pas faire sans
c'est vrai qu'un fumer je n'avais pas
senti un ténor
bah merci
c'est pour ça qu'il fallait dire terdav
s'il vous plaît pour lui acheter du
temps cet homme pour enfants il n'en va
pas te dire la même chose dans quelques
années
oui ta tro bien merci il en convient
mais arrête tout ce qu'ils ont fait où
ils n'ont pas de danse moment n'empêche
théodore des murmures dit hun sen tu
l'as fait avec qui ça ça va hein c'est
pas beau on dirait c'est en train de
virer à l'école des fans mon truc c'est
horrible à 3 du tout non mais en fait je
sais pas moi je suis je suis là pour
aussi partagez donc je peux parler
pendant des heures mais si vous avez des
questions sur alors qu'une question à
notre famille c'est ça allez-y quelqu'un
voulait poser une question ils ça une
fois deux fois
c'est la mort d'êtres oui bah elle l'a
viré le plus qui va rentrer à pied non
mais là des chaussures c'est pas sa mère
j'ai vu ses chaussures d'ailleurs [__]
bonsoir madame bonsoir à tous je
m'appelle jose d'eiffage feller
courtoise et courtoise je suis là avec
plein de monde donc des enfants et des
adultes de l'association que je préside
nationale en cours qui célébra très bien
et une association pour les parents les
familles monoparentales d'accord et donc
on propose parmi tant l'action pour les
adultes des actions pour les enfants
oui il a le désir le grand désir serait
de proposer du théâtre pour l'an
prochain pour les enfants parce que on
trouve très important justement de
pouvoir leur permettre de s'exprimer
également les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent pardon liés à la séparation
de leurs parents
d'accord
déjà un je vous invite à venir si vous
voulez faire une fois par mois à l'agora
au centre municipal d'elancourt d'accord
unis et rencontrer nos enfants mais nous
a donné beaucoup d'enfants non gilles
faut passer deux heures avec eux et puis
un peu théâtre et je veux savoir qu'est
ce qu'être conseil pouvait leur donner
ils ont entre on va dire 14 12 et 14
pour justement pouvoir avoir confiance
en eux et pouvoir aller vers les gens
alors merci grand mas migros et parle
beaucoup trop laid trop de trucs à dire
joseph à saint pée voilà vous retrouver
tout seul c'était facile
je vous la corde je vous la corde mais
c'était toute façon je fais que des
blagues comme ce à quoi le savoir c'est
pour ça que je mets en scène des gens
parce que moi même ça sert à rien arrête
toi là tu veux aller loin
tu vas le regretter bah oui alors déjà
félicitations pour votre action
parce que c'est quelque chose c'est bien
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que je peux
conseiller aux enfants moi c'est bizarre
ça c'est pas vraiment le cas j'ai
toujours aimé mes deux parents et j'ai
toujours des relations avec les deux
mais mes parents étaient séparés à un
moment et donc du coup je me suis
retrouvé dans une situation où j'étais
un peu perdue donc et je ne sais pas
comment communiquer avec les gens je ne
savais pas avant la la colère se
transforme un les mots se transformer en
en colère en ta page et ce monsieur
était sur mon chemin donc du coup j'ai
pris il a il m'a beaucoup aidé à changer
ça et en fait ça c'est ça s'est fait à
travers le théâtre donc ggsu j'essuie
m'exprimer au fur et à mesure donc
dans des personnages ça m'a beaucoup
aidé les personnages le disais c'est pas
moi c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui passe un
message
donc j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de
théâtre j'en fais encore aujourd'hui la
preuve
et du coup ça va aider vraiment à
évacuer plein de choses donc tu as
raison josefa de le théâtre était
effectivement une belle solution pour se
raconter pour se dire pour évacuer
peut-être des choses audacieuses riz cpn
aller et non mais c'est vrai et je sais
que du coup avec la maîtresse de maison
ici virginie marceau c'est pas pour rien
qu'on fait ce travail là de deux
plateaux de jeunes humoristes qui
permettent à des gens d'ici aussi de
venir s'exprimer de rencontrer des gens
comme ils ça c'est aussi ça il ya des
choses qui vont se mettre en place et
qu'on essaie de mettre en place
donc on a bien entendu ce que tu nous a
dit et je pense que c'est le théâtre est
forcément à mon choix il ça vient nous
pouvait encore là effectivement de ce
qui lui a permis à lui de se raconter et
de se dire et le fait si bien
aujourd'hui que il ya plein d'espoir en
fait à se raconter à l'arrière merci
joseph a en tout cas merci beaucoup
est ce que quelqu'un aura encore une
question pour issa associations dans la
salle qui veulent faire leur promo est
pas bon on a bien vu
ouais c'est ta pub pour la lessive la
prochaine en dhr a dit tout est permis d
eau courante est un vendredi tous
savaient pas non non tu te pas vu à la
télé non mais j'ai pas à la télé je te
jeu alors j'ai vu une main sur le chou
oui à papa bonjour j et j'aimerais bien
faire du théâtre mais j'sais pas comment
mais ce prix mais pas du tout y est
juste à côté à l'élan cours et il ya de
l'impro dans ton collège ou pas y'a un
camarade demain qu'est ce qui fait du
théâtre et du coup ça t'intéresse pas de
t'inscrire avec lui au début
au début je veux pas te cacher ça va
être dur parce qu'en fait parler devant
des gens c'est toujours compliqué mais à
un moment tu vas y prendre goût et tu va
échanger avec d autres camarades et ça
va devenir un plaisir et tu va le
transformer donc du coup essaye tu vas
voir ça va te faire beaucoup de bien
parce que tu vas jouer des personnages
et tu vas te dire mon personnage il
arrive à dire ça wahou génial et après
finalement tu vas te dire c'est pas si
compliqué dans la vie de dire les choses
qu'on pense donc du coup essaye de le
faire avec des personnages au début et
après tu vas y arriver dans la vie parce
que ma mère elle a déjà fait du théâtre
avec la piste
bah tiens bon tu sais moi ta maman comme
quoi il ya trop longtemps que je suis
dans le coin
merci
maj a laissé les enfants de trouver trop
vieux la merci ça fait plaisir a
vraiment merci j'avais vu que derrière
moi j'avais au mince j'avais une
question qu'il soit il ça peut-être que
le public ne posera pas tu es tu as
commencé par l'impro oui tu parle
effectivement cette incarnation
personnages et de travail que tu as fait
avec mappy comment tu es passé à
l'écriture et comment tu travailles en
écriture comment tu écris tes textes
alors ça ça va être un jeu racontait un
truc que j'ai peut-être des gens l'ont
déjà entendu mais je vais vous dire
comment j'ai écrit mon spectacle mon
spectacle un jour en fait c'est arthur
vous connaissez arthur qui un jour me
promenais demande en sortie des missions
il dit est ce que tu as un spectacle
j'ai dit oui et me dit ok j'aimerais
bien te rencontrer pour qu'on parle du
spectacle dit d'accord pas de problème
on était vendredi me dit on se donne
rendez vous mardi guy hoquet donc du
coup j'accepte je me dis jamais me
rappellera toujours il parle comme ça
les gens de la télé mais jamais il vous
rappellera donc du coup lundi à son
assistante qui m'appelle c'est toujours
ok pour mardi oui oui d'accord d'accord
donc je vais au rendez vous mardi et il
me dit alors c'est quoi ton spectacle
est là enfin de l'impro j'improvise un
spectacle sous ses yeux ou judy dans mon
spectacle qui assaillent à sillas
ailleurs si officie ce génial
ok je veux bien de produire ok super je
sors de là j'appelle papy je dis papy je
suis dans la merde j'ai inventé un
spectacle et j'ai dit que tu étais mon
metteur en scène il faut qu'on bosse
et c'est vrai et ça a fait mon spectacle
moi j'étais tranquille en vacances et
biba dans un mois faut qu'on ait un
spectacle ici à queue pour tout vous
dire un spectacle il faut le mature et
il faut voilà avec certains ça mais un
an deux ans lui me dit non mais c'est
moi en fait tu es mon metteur en scène
on arthur qui nous produit on n'a rien
mais dans un mois il faut qu'on présente
un spectacle jeune homme a passé un mois
d'août sympa et en fait comme ça et
comme comme la personne qui me connaît
le plus en jeu c'était papier donc j'ai
appelé directement papier on s'est
enfermés pendant un mois dans une salle
et j'avais des personnages que j'avais
déjà joué en impro dans plusieurs
spectacles ou sinon par exemple madame
conakry je l'avais créé avec toi aussi
dans la tête de la tête de l'emploi
donc du coup c'est des personnages que
je suis partie piocher un peu à droite à
gauche et je me suis dit qu'est ce que
j'ai envie de raconter et dans chaque
personnage en fait j'ai mis ce que
j'avais envie de raconter et du coup
j'ai créé mon spectacle comme ça avec
papy je n'ai jamais répéter mon
spectacle mais quand en fait j'avais
cette base de théâtre qui faisait qu' on
ne faisait pas plein de tests de
spectacle je me suis dit ben je vais y
aller comme d'habitude on fait la
première et si ça marche tant mieux si
ça marche pas tant pis et en fait
j'avais jamais répéter avant la première
de la soirée en entendre plusieurs mais
répéteur entier le spectacle et le soir
même juste avant de commencer jeudi
après ça il ya quoi papy après c'est une
fée mais en fait on a jamais répéter
entièrement le spectacle et l'achever
mais pourquoi tu m'as dis ça mais
pourquoi tu m'as dit ça allez vas-y
iqu ouais bien le spectacle a tourné
pendant trois ans en salle comble donc
très proche mois quand même qu'on ya
fait de te pousse et c'est vrai c'est
génial et du coup ça m'a permis plein de
choses ça m'a permis de partir aussi sur
un truc que je ne connaissais absolument
pas partir sur des choses écrites pas ce
que j'ai fait pendant des années des
spectacles d'improvisation
donc du coup on crée notre personnage de
notre histoire sur l'instant t et en
fait ça m'a permis de mélanger les deux
j'ai mélangé un spectacle très écrits à
des moments et à un moment ça des
moments très improvisés donc du coup
c'était avec le public j'arrivais à
créer des histoires qui sont le
spectacle faisait une heure et quart
sans septembre et à la fin il faisait 2
heures européen moi j'étais là tu en
entends disant là qu on a un peu rajouté
ou c'est moi ça va et c'était qu'il en
avait rajouté
et pourquoi ça tombe à plat 15 44 et
médiatique question ce que t'es trop
courtois
oui on vous a repéré avec votre reer est
ce qu'il y aurait encore une question ou
deux dans la salle que vous voudrez on
en profite puisque on a ce camarade là
avec nous là bas je nomme je viens jeune
homme c'est une jeune fille qui a une
casquette des filles jeudi à casquette à
la peluche à casquette comme aux yeux de
leur père mais il a du bal ce soir elle
a du mal merci beaucoup de m'avoir
confondues issa est ce que tu dirais que
l'humour tu as tu as rendu meilleur août
à sauver deux parce que tu as vécu j'ai
entendu ta question il ya eu une bonne
en même temps et gbagbo qui a dit ça
c'est ta première partie je crois c'est
un futur pas c'est le monsieur qui filme
depuis tout à l'heure c'est ça répond à
la question de la dame suppose que tu
dis ne te cache pas vilain
oui
il s'ensuit répondre à la fille à la
jeune fille tu es ce que ça m'a rendu
meilleur e
je sais pas en tout cas je sais que la
compagnie où j'ai été ma beaucoup
beaucoup formés sur ce métier est en
fait je peux que les remercier parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand je vais dans une
salle de spectacle en fait se parle avec
les techniciens
je peux très bien mettre en avant
d'autres personnes qui travaillent
autour du spectacle parce que quand j'ai
grandi dans cette compagnie déclic
théâtre
eh ben on m'a appris à ranger mon
matériel on m'a appris à dire bonjour au
revoir aux gens quand on rentre dans une
salle et quand on ressort on m'a appris
à donner de l'importance aussi aux gens
qui travaillent avec nous en les
remerciant en fin de spectacle parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'artistes et je
citerai pas de noms qui pense que tous
créé tout seul
et ils ont tous créé tout seul alors que
c'est pas vrai est vraiment un petit
détail à la con mais si vous rentrez
dans une salle que vous dit bonjour aux
techniciens que vous allez après sur
scène et que vous le remercier à la fin
et ben lui il ira à chaque fois à ce mec
là il est cool et du coup il va
travailler avec vous mais de deux avec
avec le coeur si vous arrivez vous lui
dites pas bonjour il est mal luné ils
peuvent éteindre la lumière quand il
veut ils coupent tomic on aggrave à
c'est ça qui s'est passé tout à fait
j'aurais pu leur dire bonjour mais
vraiment et cdc des détails à la con
mais en fait on travaille jamais tout
seul on n'est jamais tout seul en
spectacle même si vous voyez quelqu'un
tout seul sur scène il est pas tout seul
ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui l'ont
formé il ya des gens qui l'ont aidé à
écrire il ya des gens qui l'ont mis en
lumière il ya des gens qui ont mis un
micro cravate ou un micro pardon casque
ou un micro cravate ou un micro mais il
ya quelqu'un qui prépare en fait cette
semaine à quelqu'un qui la nettoyer
avant qu'ils montent sur 7 il ya des
gens qui travaillent avec nous et faut
pas l'oublier
donc je pense que ça c'est très très
important merci la technique
ah tiens à les remercier du coup mais du
coup t'as pas répondu à la question et
ça s'est très vite que ça m'a réussi ici
je veux répondre est ce que ça m'a rendu
meilleur je sais pas je pense que j'ai
une éducation qui fait que je j'ai
toujours respecté les gens je suis
meilleur je sais pas meilleure en jeu
peut-être parce que j'ai moins peur de
monter sur scène
meyer dans la vie je ne sais pas ça faut
le demander à mon entourage
c'est bizarre de répondre à cette
question moi même parce que on dirait
que je me vois je me regarde et je me
plaît c'est bizarre ce mois se trouve
meilleur
ouais au trivial pursuit par exemple
d'accord alors bienvenue au club j'ai va
le chercher avec sans merci julie tu
crois que tu disais est très très juste
et du coup ça fait un subtil transition
juste pour que au lieu de faire ça à la
fin du spectacle rapidement c'est
effectivement la dernière de la saison
est effectivement ces plateaux du monde
se font pas tout seul ils se font sous
l'impulsion d'une dynamique d'une équipe
dynamique incroyable juste je te coupe
vent commence à remercier les gens je
voudrais le dire juste à tous ceux qui
sont montés sur scène ne c'était super
déjà vraiment c'est à dire que il faut
pas au début on se casse la gueule
parfois c'est dur et c'est comme ça
qu'on se forment en fait faut pas avoir
peur fausse cassé les dents pour se dire
la rd théodore en fait
[Rires]
adama elle et il n'a pas encore danser
des dents de lait soit c'est ça non non
c'est décide en définitive c'est très
bien ça vous donne un départ en fait
vous dites j'ai commencé comme ça et je
peux que progresser vous pouvez pas
aller à chaque fois que vous allez
remonter sur scène vous pouvez pas aller
en dessous de ce que vous avez fait la
dernière fois je dois aller toujours de
l'avant continuer si vous voulez prenez
des auteurs des gens qui sont autour de
vous pour écrire pour vous aider à
structurer les choses mais lâchez pas
c'est pas genre j'ai fait cette scène
c'était dur c'est pas mon truc
si c'est vraiment là et ben vous y
arriverez voilà merci
du coup ma transition est toute pourrie
maintenant c'est pato se sont organisés
sous la plus jeune je voulais dire un
truc marrant et ben voila je voudrais
qu'on remercie toute l'équipe du théâtre
du prisme est particulièrement qui qui
croise en virginie garçons alexandre à
khartoum en tout le monde
tv 78,2 c'est qu'il nous a accompagnés
j'ai fait des films thor ils sont plus
en fils à ses petits prix ça c'était
avant
mais là ils sont privés 70 excusez moi
par mail fils ils ce sont leurs noms
c'était 60 18 pardon excusez moi sans
fil sans filet et les 78 tout à fait des
slogans et on est vraiment heureux que
l'humour
voilà soit en résidence ici ça
continuera l'année prochaine et ou pas
on vient de nous apprendre que notre
salaire a été multiplié par dix papilles
alors ça quand tu n'es semaines quand
ils les ont tous mangé dès samedi on va
on va peut-être clôturer cette dernière
alors à temps parce que quand même à
l'étude
je crois qu'il faut quand même qu'on si
on est là c'est pas pour rien il ya
vraiment quelqu'un c'est tout ça moi je
tiens mon chapeau quand même à virginie
ouais ouais
et la patronne la main à la pâte en de
cette maison qui nous habite
merci didier d'avoir pensé à nous pour
faire ça et bravo bravo au travail que
tu fais au quotidien pour faire c'est la
maison et ça va on bricole nous qu'est
ce qui se passe mais j'ai retrouvé
la fille de pierre richard mais
messieurs bonsoir merci on pourrait vous
applaudir vous deux
julie chaise tapis papilles
[Musique]
tant que big n
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non